es un mal momento para los consumidores
estadounidenses
según las últimas cifras de la oficina
de estadísticas laborales la tasa
interanual de inflación en eeuu subió en
noviembre hasta el 6.8 por ciento seis
décimas por encima de la de octubre
representa la cifra de inflación
interanual más alta desde junio de 1982
sin embargo el presidente baiden trató
de restar importancia a esas cifras
calificando la alta inflación de este
año como transitoria al respective y con
todos los demás aspectos de la economía
van a toda velocidad van increíblemente
bien aunque hemos tenido este tipo de
crecimiento en 60 años pero es cierto
que la inflación está afectando en la
vida de la gente los precios han subido
en la mayor economía del mundo debido a
una serie de factores como la escasez de
trabajadores la elevada demanda de
bienes y la reactivación de las
industrias que se vieron afectadas por
la pandemia de kobe 19
la inflación en eeuu es casi el doble de
la europea ambos sufrimos los mismos
problemas de la cadena global pero eeuu
emprendió un programa de estímulo mucho
más agresivo que en este momento creo
que podemos decir que fue excesivo
la subida generalizada estuvo encabezada
por los precios de la gasolina que
aumentaron un 6.1 por ciento en
comparación con el año anterior los
precios de la energía también subieron
en octubre un 3.5 por ciento mientras
que los precios de los alimentos
subieron un 0.7 por ciento y ese aumento
del coste de la vida se está viendo
reflejado en los índices de aprobación
del presidente en yo vaivén de los
últimos meses